This is Hayden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There are so many universals in the human experience. Hunger, thirst, lust, fear, they drive us as much as they did humans a hundred, a thousand, or even a hundred thousand years ago. But there are also experiences that feel unique to our current moment that only modern humans have encountered. Among them, the many competing forces desperately seeking our attention. The social media and news apps pushing alerts to our phones, the streaming TV services, and yes, podcasts offering us endless opportunities to binge our favorite shows. All this clamoring for our attention can be exhausting. It reminded us of an episode we did a little while back about how our attention is being constantly harvested
我是海登·布莱恩，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。人类体验中有许多共同点。饥饿、干渴、欲望、恐惧，它们驱动着我们，就像驱动一百年前、一千年前，甚至十万年前的人类一样。但也有一些体验是我们这个时代所独有的，只有现代人才会遇到。其中之一，就是许多相互竞争的力量在拼命寻求我们的关注。社交媒体和新闻应用向我们的手机推送提醒，流媒体电视服务，当然还有播客，为我们提供了无数沉浸式观看喜爱节目的机会。所有这些对我们注意力的争夺可能会让人精疲力竭。这让我们想起不久前做过的一期节目，关于我们的注意力是如何被不断收割和劫持的。埃丝特·布莱（Esther Blye）成长的家庭中，母亲让厨房远离食用色素和高果糖玉米糖浆。埃丝特的午餐盒也遵循同样的规则。所以我会有糖脆豆，会有橙子，有时会有剩菜，可能还会有一包软糖，但那必须是健康软糖。当然，埃丝特渴望同学们正在吃的加工零食和麦片。电视广告助长了她的欲望。特里克斯先生，同学们正在吃的加工零食和麦片。
and hijacked. Esther Blye grew up with a mom who kept her kitchen free from food coloring and high fructose corn syrup. Esther's lunch box was subject to the same rules. So I would have snap peas, I would have an orange, sometimes you would be leftovers, and one maybe like gummy snack, but it would only be like health gummy. Of course, Esther craved the processed snacks and cereals that her classmates were eating. Television commercials fueled her desire. Mr. Crave, the processed snacks and cereals that her classmates were eating.
电视广告助长了她的欲望。她最喜欢的广告之一是特里克斯（Trix）酸奶的广告。它是黑白的。嘿，这是从家里带的。特里克斯，兔子，就在这个服装里。我太想摆出一副快乐的面孔了。当你拥有特里克斯时，你就不是坏人。他开始描述所有那些，你知道，并不真实，但表现得像真实一样的美妙水果。
Television commercials fueled her desire. One of her favorites was for Tricks Yogurt. It's black and white. Hey, a pack is from home. Tricks, rabbit, is inside of this costume. I'm too put on a happy face. When you've got Tricks, you're not a bad guy. And he starts describing all the wonderful fruits that, you know, aren't real, but they
草莓香蕉大狂欢，树莓彩虹！噢，不！是那只兔子！是傻兔子。当孩子们咬下一口时，他们开始变色，最后一切都变成了彩色。它为你的世界带来了色彩。当然，特里克斯酸奶被禁止进入布莱家的冰箱，
act like they're real. Strawberry banana bash, raspberry rainbow! Uh-oh! It's the rabbit! It's silly, rabbit. As the kid take a bite, they start to turn the color, and at the very end, everything's like technicolour. It brings color to your world. Now, Trix Yoga, of course, was banned from the Bly family fridge,
因为它含有的人工香料和食用色素。但在早餐时间，埃丝特说她妈妈允许她有一个唯一的含糖例外。所以我被鼓励吃含糖麦片，除非她或我父亲小时候吃过。所以这是一种怀旧的宽容。今天在《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们将探讨广告商、科技公司和网红如何利用这种怀旧宽容以及人类行为的其他方面来捕获我们的注意力。就像你父母让你早餐吃磨砂片（Frosted Flakes）和幸运符（Lucky Charms）麦片，因为他们小时候早餐就吃这些。如果你仔细想想，父母喜欢让他们的孩子体验他们曾经体验过的同样美好的事物。
because it had artificial flavors and food colorings. But at breakfast time, Esther says her mom allowed her one solitary sugary exception. So I was an encourage to have sugary cereals, unless possibly her or my father had had them growing up. So it was kind of that nostalgic allowance. Today on Hidden Brain, how advertisers, tech companies and influencers exploit this nostalgia allowance and other aspects of human behavior to capture our attention. As your parents let her have frosted flakes and lucky charms for breakfast because they ate frosted flakes and lucky charms for breakfast because they ate frosted flakes and lucky charms for breakfast when they were kids. If you think about it, parents love to have their kids experience the same wonderful things
这是玛丽·布鲁克斯教授。我在亚利桑那大学埃勒管理学院工作。我对广告效应的心理学很感兴趣。玛丽说，不仅仅是含糖麦片的味道和气味在我们的脑海中巩固了记忆。是广告在销售这些产品。对于六七岁的孩子来说，像幸运矮妖和
that they did. This is Professor Mary Brooks. I work at the Elearchalogy Management at the University of Arizona. And I'm interested in the psychology of advertising effects. Mary says it isn't just the taste and smell of sugary cereals that cement memories in our minds. It's the advertising that sells those products. For a six or seven year old, commercials with fun mascots like Lucky the Lepricon and
托尼老虎这样有趣的吉祥物的广告可能非常有影响力。孩子们很容易受到那些有趣、听起来不错、可以跟着唱且有有趣角色的信息的影响，因为他们的思想对这一切非常开放。他们对一切都持开放态度。年幼的孩子并不怀疑。他们不会听着带有可爱兔子的广告想，一家价值数十亿美元的公司正试图影响我。当然，在某个时刻，这种情况会改变，孩子们开始把广告视为广告。想必你对我们脆弱或易受影响的窗口何时打开和关闭有一些想法。
Tony the Tiger can be really powerful. Children are vulnerable to messages that are fun and sound good and you can sing and they have fun characters because their minds are just so open to all of that. They're open to everything. Small children are not skeptical. They don't listen to commercials with cute rabbits and think, a multi-billion dollar company is trying to influence me. Of course at a certain point this changes and kids start to think of commercials as commercials. Presumably you have some ideas on when the window opens and closes in terms of our vulnerability
那个窗口是什么样的？研究表明——虽然我不确定我是否相信——这种脆弱性在13岁左右结束，就认知能力而言，这意味着孩子们对广告是什么、它是如何运作的以及他们不应该对其开放有了理解。他们应该进行批判性思考，
or impressionability. What does that window look like? The research says, and I'm not sure I believe it, that the vulnerability ends around 13 in terms of your cognitive ability, meaning children's understanding of what advertising is and how it works and that they should not be open to it. They should be thinking critically,
同时，当他们听到广告时，他们能够质疑它。这是一个有趣的问题。当我们小时候听到的那些信息会发生什么？我们成年后的思想会质疑它们吗？为了回答这个问题，玛丽与两位同事合作。石溪大学的保罗·康奈尔。还有我在这里的一位教授同事，
and they're able to, at the same time, they're hearing it, question it. Here's the interesting question. What happens to those messages that we heard when we were small? Do our grown-up minds question them? To answer that question, Mary teamed up with two colleagues. Paul Connell at Stony Brook University. And one of my professor colleagues here,
他的名字叫杰斯珀·尼尔森。三人安排了一系列研究，观察成年人如何看待麦片产品。我们想做的第一件事是确定我们可以将人们对产品营养价值的信念与他们童年时期对该产品的接触联系起来。他们在英国收集了一组人，并要求他们评价一种名为“可可泡泡”（Cocoa Pops）的巧克力膨化米麦片的健康程度。
his name is Jesper Nielsen. And the trio arranged a series of studies to look at how adults viewed serial products. First thing we wanted to do is to establish that we can tie people's beliefs about the nutritiousness of a product with their exposure to that product when they were children. They gathered a sample of people in the United Kingdom and asked them to rate the healthfulness
可可泡泡，旋转陀螺，可可泡泡，它很火。对于麦片鉴赏家来说，可可泡泡不应与美国听众可能从小吃到大的“可可泡”（Cocoa Puffs）混淆。可可泡泡的吉祥物是一只戴着蓝色棒球帽的微笑猴子。研究中的一些人直到成年才了解可可泡泡，而另一些人则是从小吃这种麦片长大的，并且在小时候看过它的广告。那些人给它的营养价值评价要高得多。
of a chocolate puffed rice cereal called cocoa pops. Cocoa pops, spinning tops, cocoa pops, it's hot. For cereal connoisseurs, cocoa pops are not to be confused with the coco-pops that American listeners may have grown up eating. The coco-pops mascot is a smiling monkey wearing a blue baseball cap. Some people in the study only learned about coco-pops when they were adults, others grew up eating the cereal, and had seen commercials for it when they were small kids. Those people rated as much more nutritious.
所以除了那些小时候见过它并对可可猴有喜爱和温暖感觉的人之外，其他所有人都对它的营养价值有更准确的评价。你注意到那句台词了吗？“营养早餐的一部分”。麦片广告经常使用这样的语言。现在，如果你是一个持怀疑态度的成年人，你可能会猜到一种成分中含有可可或棉花糖的麦片并不是你最健康的选择。但如果你是个孩子，“营养早餐”听起来相当不错。那么，当你长大后，你的大脑不应该纠正你小时候那个易受影响的大脑所犯的错误吗？嗯，对我来说，可怕的事情之一是成年人
So everyone else has a more accurate rating of how nutritious this is except for the people who saw it as a child and who have feelings of liking and warmth towards the cocoa monkey. Did you catch that line? Part of a nutritious breakfast. Serial commercials often use language like this. Now, if you're a skeptical adult, you might guess that a serial with cocoa or marshmallows in the ingredients is not your healthiest option. But if you're a kid, a nutritious breakfast sounds pretty good. So shouldn't your grown-up brain correct for the mistakes of your impressionable brain when you were a kid? Well, to me, one of the scary things is adults
并没有纠正它。他们后来并没有说，你知道，我有这些童年记忆，它们是错的。我真的应该重新思考一下。所以在我们后来的研究中，我们实际检查的就是，如果我们要帮助他们，例如提醒他们健康，或者提醒他们儿童对广告的脆弱性，如果我们要帮助他们，例如提醒他们健康，或者提醒他们
don't correct for it. They don't later on say, you know, I have these memories from when I was a child and you know, they're wrong. I really should rethink that. So in our later studies, that's what we actually checked is would people, if we help them, by reminding them of health, for example, or reminding them of children's vulnerability to advertising, that if we help them, like reminding them of health, for example, or reminding them
儿童对广告的脆弱性，如果我们这样做，他们会纠正这些偏见吗？我们再次发现，那些对这些角色怀有情感的人并没有纠正它。那么普通成年人不应该能够说，看，我小时候喜欢这个吉祥物，但我不再是孩子了。我现在太老了，不会相信幼稚的东西。所以我应该把它放在一边。
of children's vulnerability to advertising, that if we were to do that, would they then correct these biases? And what we found, again, is that the people who felt that emotion towards these characters did not correct for it. So shouldn't the average adult be able to say, look, I like the mascot when I was a child, but I'm not a child anymore. I'm too old now to believe in childish things. So I should just set it aside.
我想如果你问大多数成年人，你想表现得幼稚吗？他们会说不。为什么这种影响仍然存在？如果我们想把童年听到的东西抛在脑后，为什么它们的影响仍然留在我们的脑海中？嗯，你必须真的想把它们抛在脑后。所以我认为这是一种个体差异。有些人确实远离了他们小时候喜欢的东西。但如果你仔细想想，父母喜欢让他们的孩子体验他们曾经体验过的同样美好的事物，
I think if you ask most adults, do you want to behave childishly? They will say no. Why is this effect still persisting? Why does the the effects of what we hear in childhood Stay in our minds if we want to leave those behind in a way? Well, you'd have to really want to leave those behind So I think that's an individual difference. It's some people do move away from The love of the things they had as kids. But if you think about it, parents love to have their kids experience the same wonderful things that they did,
这就是为什么父母喜欢带孩子去迪士尼，喜欢和他们分享他们曾经拥有的玩具，我认为他们仍然热爱这些东西。还记得埃丝特吗？她注重健康的父母为磨砂片破了例，因为他们是伴随着托尼老虎长大的，而且不仅仅是在麦片盒上。托尼老虎，我奶奶，仍然留着那个垃圾桶。
which is why parents love to take their kids to Disney, and they love to share with them the toys that they had, and I think that they still love these things. Remember Esther? Her health-conscious parents made an exception for frosted flakes because they grew up with Tony the Tiger, and not just on the cereal box. Tony the Tiger, my grandma, still kept the trash can.
所以我们有一个非常古老的家乐氏垃圾桶，上面有托尼老虎，这是他60、70年代最早的设计之一。麦片吉祥物似乎拥有不可思议的力量。埃丝特告诉我们那个让她印象深刻的特里克斯酸奶广告，但她也记得特定的水果圈（Froot Loops）广告。是的，我真的很喜欢大嘴鸟山姆，因为他会去探索，还有奥利奥麦片。有跳舞的奥利奥人物，这让我想起了《飞天法宝》的广告。她甚至从未尝试过奥利奥麦片，但她仍然对它有一种奇怪的喜爱。对于孩子们来说，讲故事非常容易，尤其是当你让吉祥物参与进来时。
So we have this very old Kellogg trash can with Tony the Tiger, one of his very first designs from the 6070s. Serial mascots appear to have incredible power. Esther told us about the trick-seogard ad that stuck with her, but she also remembers specific ads for fruit loops. Yeah, I really like Santa 2 can because you would go and explore and an Oreo cereal. There's the dancing Oreo figures and it reminded me of the flubber ad. She's never even tried the Oreo one, but she still feels a kind of strange fondness for it. For kids telling a story, it's very easy to do, especially when you have mascot involvement.
2016年，部分基于玛丽·布鲁克斯进行的研究，智利禁止在所有产品包装上使用吉祥物，并开展了一场媒体运动，教育人们了解更健康的食品。吉祥物已从薯片到麦片的各种产品中移除。一些食品上还贴上了黑色贴纸，标签如“高热量”或“高糖”。我问玛丽她认为这是否有效。
In 2016, based in part on research studies like the one Mary Brooks conducted, the country of Chile banned mascots from all product packaging and launched a media campaign to educate people about healthier foods. mascots have been removed from all sorts of products, from chips to cereals. Some foods also have a black sticker slapped on them with labels like alto and caloreas, high in calories, or alto and azucarides, high in sugar. I asked Mary if she thinks it'll work.
基于我的研究，我会全力支持这项努力。如果他们做了10年而没有效果，那么我们应该回到原来的样子。但我认为它会奏效。我只是认为你不会在很长一段时间内看到结果，因为这些影响是长期积累的。玛丽自己也记得童年时期让她印象深刻的广告，这些广告已经伴随她几十年了。
Based on my research, I would be fully supportive of that effort. If they do it for 10 years and it doesn't work, well, then we should go back to what it is. But I think it will work. I just don't think you're going to see the result for a long time, because these effects build up over a long time. Mary herself remembers commercials from her childhood that have stuck with her for several decades.
我记得和朋友们走着去小学，唱着温斯顿（Winston）的广告歌。这就是为什么抽温斯顿的人比抽任何其他过滤嘴香烟的人多。当我换成温斯顿，我就永远换了，因为它有像我预料的那样好的味道。还有任何其他过滤嘴香烟。温斯顿，味道好，就像香烟应该有的那样。这是一个令人不安的画面。小学生唱着关于吸烟美德的歌。你可能认为作为一个社会，我们会决定减少让孩子接触广告，但事实上，正如
I have a memory of walking to elementary school with my friends, singing the Winston jingle. That's why more people smoke Winston than any other builder cigarette. When I change to Winston, I change for good, because I got good taste like a new I would. And any other filter cigarette. Winston, tastes good, like a cigarette shirt. It's a disturbing image. Elementary schoolers singing a song about the virtues of smoking. You might think that as a society we would decide to expose our children to fewer advertisements, but in fact as a
加利福尼亚的一个学区所展示的那样，我们可能正朝着完全相反的方向前进。早在2012年，双河联合学区（Twin Rivers Unified School District）资金短缺。捐助者介入并提出帮助。但有一个小小的附加条件。捐助者想要一些回报。这是哥伦比亚大学研究员蒂姆·吴（Tim Wu）。他们想要的不仅仅是学生的注意力。所以他们提议，如果学校同意让学生接触广告，覆盖储物柜上的广告，一些课堂广告，食堂里的广告，学校就可以获得所有——不是所有的钱，但大部分财富。
school district in California shows we might be going in exactly the opposite direction. Back in 2012 the Twin Rivers Unified School District was strapped for cash. Benefactors stepped in and offered to help. But there was one small catch. The benefactors wanted something in exchange. Here's Columbia University researcher, Tim Wu. They wanted nothing less than the attention of the students. So they proposed that the school could have all, not all the money, wants, but great riches of it only agreed to subject its students to advertising, covering the lockers with ads, some in class advertisements, ads in the cafeteria.
这是学校在资金短缺时偶尔转向其被俘受众（即学生）这一大趋势的一部分。偶尔转向其被俘受众，即学生。休息之后，蒂姆将揭开当今数百万美元广告业的帷幕。你知道，1910年代的广告商并不羞于吹嘘他们的力量。我记得一个叫克劳德·霍普金斯（Claude Hopkins）的人吹嘘说，我们虽然不出名，但我们控制着全美人民想要什么和做什么。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
And it's part of a big trend where schools that are strapped for cash have occasionally turned to their captive audiences, namely their students. occasionally turn to their captive audiences, namely their students. After the break, Tim will pull back the curtain on today's multi-million dollar advertising industry. You know, the advertisers in the 1910s were not shy to boast of their powers. I can remember a man named Cloud Hopkins bragging, We are not known, but we control what people all across America want and do. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and you're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
大多数人不喜欢广告。我们在浏览器上安装广告拦截器，并为流媒体服务付费，这样我们就可以跳过广告。但尽管我们做出了英勇的努力，公司还是发现了捕获我们注意力的极其有效的方法，尤其是在我们没有意识到的时候。跳过YouTube广告的按钮有时会消失。那个在Instagram上有百万粉丝的运动员开始发布乳清蛋白粉的折扣码。
Most people don't like ads. We install ad blockers on our browsers and pay for streaming services so we can skip the commercials. But despite our valiant efforts, companies have discovered remarkably effective ways to capture our attention, especially when we don't realize it. The button to skip YouTube ads sometimes vanishes. That athlete with a million followers on Instagram starts posting discount codes for way protein powder.
我们可能会失去自由，并因为做我们认为是自愿选择的事情而真正被困住。我们已经探讨了广告如何影响我们的思想。在节目的下一部分，我们将探讨名流、企业家和媒体公司如何劫持我们的注意力，以便向我们展示广告。我们从19世纪初的一个故事开始，当时纽约市的报纸行业一片惨淡。《纽约时报》当时还没出现，但有少数其他报纸，如《商业杂志》、
We can lose our freedom and become entrapped really by doing what we think are voluntary choices. We've explored how advertisements influence our minds. In the next segment of our show, we explore how celebrities, entrepreneurs and media companies hijack our attention in order to present us with ads. We begin with a story from the early 1800s when the newspaper business in New York City was bleak. The New York Times wasn't around yet, but there were a handful of other papers, the Journal
《晨报》和《纽约问询报》。它们通常每份收费6美分，在那时是一大笔钱。本杰明·戴（Benjamin Day）当时在报纸印刷厂工作，他认为商业模式需要重启。6美分太贵了。他决定创办自己的报纸《纽约太阳报》，并以1美分的价格出售。每个人都认为他疯了，但他知道一些他们不知道的事情。他的策略是杰夫·贝佐斯（Jeff Bezos）会欣赏的。
of Commerce, the Morning Courier in New York Inquirer. They typically charged $0.06 a copy, which was a lot of money in those days. Benjamin Day was working in newspaper printing and he thought the business model needed a reboot. Six cents was way too much. He decided to start his own paper, The New York Sun, and sell it for one cent. Everyone thought he was crazy, but he knew something that they didn't. His strategy was one that Jeff Bezos from Amazon could appreciate.
亚马逊会欣赏的。1835年8月25日，号外号外，快来看。《纽约太阳报》在头版刊登了一篇题为《伟大的天文发现》的文章。读者了解到，一位南非的天文学家制造了一台望远镜，可以看到月球表面微小的细节。在接下来的几周里，太阳报发布了一连串的新发现。月球上有峡谷、海洋、森林。
Amazon could appreciate. On August 25, 1835, extra extra read all about it. The New York Sun ran a front-page story titled Great Astronomical Discovery's Waitingly Maid. Readers learned that an astronomer and South Africa had built a telescope that could see minute details on the surface of the moon. Over the next few weeks, the sun released a stream of new findings. The moon contained canyons, oceans, forests.
望远镜还发现了一种新的生命形式，一种学名为“Vespotelio Homo”的生物。它看起来像一个长着蝙蝠翅膀的人类。报纸是这样描述这种生物的：平均身高四英尺，除了脸部外，全身覆盖着短而有光泽的铜色毛发，背上长着没有毛发的薄膜翅膀，紧贴在背上。而且显然有强烈的性欲。显然，这家报纸在兜售假新闻。
The telescope also identified a new form of life, a creature with a scientific name, Vespotelio Homo. It looked like a human with bat wings. Here's how the newspaper described the creature. The averaged four feet in height were covered except on the face with short and glossy copper-colored hair and had wings composed of a thin membrane without hair lying snugly upon their backs. And apparently a ferocious sexual appetite. Obviously, the paper was peddling fake news.
但这只是对我们21世纪的人来说显而易见。对于1835年的普通人来说，发现月球蝙蝠是不可思议的。对于《纽约太阳报》来说，它将报纸的发行量推向了无与伦比的水平。哥伦比亚大学法学教授蒂姆·吴写了一本名为《注意力商人》（The Attention Merchants）的书，他在书中讲述了我们的注意力被劫持的多种方式的历史。通过以一便士的价格出售报纸，本杰明·戴占领了市场份额，这结果
But that's only obvious to us in the 21st century. To the average person in 1835, the discovery of moon bats was incredible. And for the New York Sun, It carried the paper to unrivaled levels of circulation. Columbia University Law Professor Tim Wu has written a book titled The Attention Merchants, where he recounts the history of the many ways our attention has been hijacked. By selling the newspaper for a penny, Benjamin Day captured market share, and this turned
产生了比新闻纸更有价值的东西。《纽约太阳报》刊登了这些故事，是第一份完全依靠收割人类注意力来运营的报纸，也就是我们所说的广告商业模式。因此，它的利润完全不取决于其可信度或其他任何东西，而取决于它能转售多少读者。所以这是一个关键的历史时刻，开始了将注意力作为一种非常有价值的商品进行商品化，
out to produce something much more valuable than Newsprint. The New York Sun, which published these stories, was the first paper to run entirely on the harvesting of human attention, what we also call an advertising business model. And so its profits entirely depended not on its credibility or anything else, but how many readers it had that it could resell. So that was a crucial historic moment that began the commodification of attention as something very valuable
你可以转售并赚很多钱。这就是为什么我认为报纸会被驱动去报道发现月球生命这样的故事，以便建立发行量。本杰明·戴的商业模式是一个深刻的发现。一个让我感到高兴的模式。那个模式在今天依然活跃。注意力是让从糖果制造商到汽车经销商的所有人都能销售其商品的燃料。
that you could resell make a lot of money out of. And that's why I think the paper was driven to stories such as discovering life on the moon so it could build a circulation. Benjamin Day's business model was a profound discovery. One, I am pleased for me. That model is alive and well today. Attention is the fuel that allows everyone from candy makers to car dealers to sell their wares.
事实上，注意力是如此强大，以至于一旦你拥有了它，你就能让人们购买他们甚至不知道自己需要的东西。比如，漱口水。在1920年代，李施德林（Listerine）提出了蒂姆所说的“需求工程”的第一个例子。这是一个围绕一个不熟悉的词“口臭”（Halitosis）建立的广告活动。广告声称，这种可怕的情况会让你不受欢迎。是的，你知道，我不认为人们在1910年代或1920年代之前会考虑他们是否有口臭。在那个时代，一种新的广告形式
In fact, attention is so powerful that once you have it, you can get people to buy things, they didn't even know they needed. Like for example, Mouthwash. In the 1920s, Lissdreen came up with one of the first examples of something Tim calls demand engineering. It was an advertising campaign built around an unfamiliar word, Halitosis. This dreaded condition, the ad claimed, makes you unpopular. Yeah, well, you know, I don't think people thought much about whether they had bad breath or not before the 1910s or 1920s. In that era, new form of advertising was
本质上被发明出来，其目标是设计一种并不一定已经存在的需求。它被视为由专业人士完成的科学过程。并且对于支持那些否则可能卖不出去的新产品是必要的，漱口水就是其中之一，牙膏是另一种，人们并不一定想要它们。关键在于，你可以获取你收割到的一定程度的人类注意力，然后通过设计新的需求将其转化或纺织成黄金。
essentially invented, which the goal of which was to engineer a demand that did not already necessarily exist. It was seen as a scientific process done by professionals. And necessary to support new products that might otherwise not sell, mouthwash being one of them, a toothpaste being another, people didn't necessarily want them. The key there is that you could take human attention, which you've harvested, to some extent, and then transform it or spin it into gold
这就是1920年代广告的魔力或科学，让人们想要他们本来不想要的东西。那么蒂姆，我了解到李施德林的销售额从11.5万美元增长到超过800万美元，这是这次广告活动的结果。是的，没错。而且19世纪，特别是1920年代，有大量的例子证明
by engineering new demands. And that was the magic or the science of advertising in the 1920s to make people want things they didn't otherwise want. So Tim, I understand that Listerine sales grew from $115,000 to over $8 million as a result of this advertising campaign. Yeah, that's right. And there are abundant examples from the 19,s, particularly in the 1920s, of
需求工程是有效的。坦率地说，这推动了所谓的广告业的增长，在此之前它确实是一个边缘行业。以李施德林为例，它之前被用于不明确的用途，它曾是消毒剂，曾作为清洁地板的东西出售，但将其发明为治疗口臭的漱口水是其成功的关键。1920年代的注意力商人发现，他们不仅可以创造新的规范，还可以打破旧的规范。
demand engineering working. That's what powered, frankly, the growth of something called an advertising industry, which beforehand really been a marginal industry. In Listerine, to take a specific example, had previously been used for unclear purposes, it had been disinfectant, it had been sold as something to clean floors with, but the invention of it as a mouthwash to clear to cure bad breath was a key to its success. The attention merchants of the 1920s discovered that they could not only create new norms, but they could undo old ones.
最有效的活动之一是破坏反对女性吸烟的禁忌。女性在公共场合吸烟甚至吸烟本身被认为是不体面的禁忌。烟草业，特别是好彩（Lucky Strike），从两个方向瞄准了这一点。一个是试图将香烟品牌化为女性独立的象征，并将其与妇女参政运动共同品牌化。他们发明了
One of the most effective campaigns was to undermine the taboo against women smoking. It was considered unseemly taboo for a woman to smoke in public or even to smoke at all. And the tobacco industry, particularly Lucky Strike, took aim in that in two directions. One was to try to brand cigarettes as a symbol of women's independence and co-brand it with the suffragement movement. They invented
“自由火炬”这个词来指代香烟，以表明女性掌握着自己的命运。第二个是久经考验的广告技巧，就是将香烟与减肥联系起来。那个时代的好彩广告画着一个巨大的胖女人，写着：这是五年后的你吗？抽好彩香烟，或者伸手拿好彩而不是甜食？所以他们确实直接针对这一点，统计数据非常惊人。
this phrase, a torches of freedom to refer to the cigarette to show that women were in charge of their own destiny. And the second, which is a well-tried advertising technique, was to link cigarettes to weight loss. There's lucky strike advertisements in the era that picture an enormous fat woman and says, is this you in five years, smoke lucky strikes or reach for a lucky knot for a sweet? So they certainly went right at it and the statistics are dramatic.
他们的销量从很少增长到专门向女性销售数百万箱。所以我认为这是需求工程最成功的例子之一。为了你喜欢的牙齿，点燃一支好彩。重新点燃。这是点燃的时间。90年前，你可能通过一种正在席卷美国的新媒介听到了那个好彩的广告歌。
They went from very little sales to many millions of cartons being sold to women specifically. And so I think it's one of the most successful examples of demand engineering. For the teeth that you like, light up a lucky strike. Relight. It's light of time. 90 years ago, you might have heard that lucky strike jingle through a new medium that was taking America by storm.
广播不仅捕获了人们的注意力，还将他们聚集在一起。家庭聚集在壁炉旁听罗斯福总统的演讲。我最紧迫的关注是执行伟大工作计划的目标，就像《纽约太阳报》在印刷品中所做的那样，奥逊·威尔斯（Orson Welles）在广播中所做的那样。大多数剧院和明星带来了汽油，奥逊·威尔斯。我们现在知道，这为注意力商人开辟了新的途径。广告商开始赞助节目，并经常将公司和产品的名称滑入节目中。试试Rinsol。
Radio didn't just capture people's attention, it brought them together. Families gathered around the fireplace to listen to FDR. My most immediate concern is in carrying out the purposes of the great work program that the New York Sun did in print, Orson Wells did on radio. The majority of the theatre and starleties brought gas, Orson Wells. We know now that opened up new avenues for attention merchants. Advertisers began sponsoring programs and often slipped the names of companies and products into shows. Try Rinsol.
我知道你会加入那支庞大的女性大军，她们在洗涤时吹着口哨。现在，新的肥皂味浓郁的Rinsol，新的肥皂味浓郁的Rinsol呈现新的Amosanandi秀。广播的公共属性以一种报纸出版商只能梦想的方式利用了注意力。你知道，19世纪、20世纪初有一些关于群体心理学的著作。有一种想法，虽然不是当代心理学，
I know you'll join the vast army of women who whistle while they wash. And now the new soapy rich Rinsol, the new Zopi Ridge Rinseo presents the new Amosanandi show. The communal aspect of radio, harnessed attention in a way that newspaper publishers could only dream of. You know, there were some 19th century, early 20th century writing on the psychology of the crowd. There was the idea, not exactly contemporary psychology,
即人们集体听东西时，会摆脱他们的个人身份，成为一个表现得更像动物的群体的一部分。在某些方面是完全野性的。这就是猜测，我们有点失去了它。我认为这种观点有一些支持。我的意思是，如果你曾经参加过体育赛事或政治集会，你觉得你已经把自己沉浸在一个群体中，但你知道，那是在那种理论化水平上，没有比这更科学的了。如果广播出现并本质上表明，你知道，它可以让报纸蒙羞，
that people listening to things in mass sort of shed their individual identity and became part of a group which behaved more like an animal. And in some ways was entirely wild. And that was the speculation that we sort of lost it. I think there's some support for that view. I mean, if you've ever been at a sports event or a political rally and you feel you sort of have submerged yourself into a group, but you know, it was at that level of theorizing nothing more scientific than that. If radio came along and essentially showed that, you know, it could put newspapers to shame,
1950年代出现了一种新产品，它很快证明它成为捕获人们注意力的主导方式。你说注意力商人历史上非凡的事情发生在1956年9月9日星期日。是的，这就是我所说的“峰值注意力”，也就是埃尔维斯·普雷斯利（Elvis Presley）出现在埃德·沙利文秀（Ed Sullivan Show）上，它注册的观众份额从未被超越。虽然有更大的观众群，但观众份额从未像那天那样大。这可能是我一生中获得的最高荣誉。
a new product emerged in the 1950s and it quickly proved that it became the dominant way to capture people's attention. You say that something extraordinary in the history of the attention merchants happened on Sunday September 9th, 1956. Yes, and that is what I label peak attention, otherwise known as Elvis Presley appearing on the Ed Sullivan show, which registered an audience share, which has never been rivaled. They've been larger audiences, but the share of the audiences has never been quite as large as on that day. This is probably the greatest honor that I've ever had in my life.
电视，甚至超越了广播，展现了这种同时捕获整个国家、观看相同信息的能力。回想起来，这很了不起。想想今天人们是多么分裂，他们都听自己的流媒体。整个国家同时观看一件事，确实是中世纪的产物，这是以前从未平等的，也许在某些方面以后也从未平等过。你知道，在广播和电视出现之前的很长一段时间里，如果你想要人们的注意力，你实际上必须在看起来像公共广场的地方捕获它。
And television, even beyond radio, had shown this incredible capacity to capture the entire nation at one time, watching the same information. In retrospect, it's remarkable. Think about today how divided people are, how they all listen to their own streams. The whole nation watching one thing at once is really a product of the mid-century and something that was never equal before and maybe in some ways never equal since. You know, it used to be that for a long time before radio and television that if you wanted people's attention, you actually had to capture it in something that looked like the public
当然，随着广播和电视的出现，就注意力商人而言，你拥有了一种即使在人们在家中时也能向他们销售东西的能力。所以家变成了一个捕获这种巨大思维空间的机会，如果你愿意的话，这种国家的注意力。是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的发展。一个20年代的人认为，你知道，家里的广播广告，
square. And of course, with the advent of radio and television, what you have as far as the attention marchions are concerned is an ability to sell things to people even when they're inside their own home. So the home becomes an opportunity to capture this enormous mind space, if you will, this attention of the nation. Yes, I think that's a very significant development. One that people in the 20s thought, you know, radio advertisements in the home,
没有人会忍受那个。家是一个神圣的地方，家庭的地方。你知道，无法想象你会接受家里的商业调侃。噢，不。Gadium。接受家里的商业调侃，呃……赶上，呃……我希望有人能发明一种喷射的番茄酱瓶，波特太太。
no one's going to stand for that. The home is a sacred place, place for family. You know, it's impossible to imagine that you'll have acceptance of commercial banter in the home. Uh-oh. Gadium. acceptance of commercial banter in the home uh... catch up uh... i wish somebody would invent a catch a bottle at squirts where you aim it missus porter
我有下一个最好的东西，宝洁公司的一项新发明。它像魔法一样吸收，它叫Bounty，这种新的纸巾实际上吸引了更多，你知道，但它伴随着很多很多甜味剂，埃尔维斯·普雷斯利，其他广播节目，《我爱露西》。所以我们达到了一个情况，即美国的每个人都会，你知道，在晚餐后坐下来，看电视。
i've got the next best thing a new invention from proctor in gamble it absorbs like magic it's called bounty the new paper towel that actually attract more you know but it came with a lot of lot of sweeteners, Elvis Presley, other radio shows, I love Lucy. And so we reached a situation where everyone in the United States would, you know, facefully sit down after dinner, watch television.
在此过程中，吸收了大量以最引人注目的形式出现的商业广告，即全声和全视频。这是一种了不起的转变，几乎了不起地允许商业以这种方式侵入，但正如我所说，它不是用棍子，而是用胡萝卜。到1950年代末，当然，人们对他们在电视上看到的广告数量感到退缩，一种新产品出现以迎合这种担忧，这种产品就是遥控器。这个装置的想法是它将允许你自由地
And in the course of that, absorb massive amount of commercial advertising in its most compelling form, namely full sound and full video. And it's remarkable transformations, almost remarkably allowed commerce to intrude in that way, but it fell, as I said, not with a stick, but with a carrot. By the late 1950s, of course, people are recoiling from the amount of advertising they're seeing on television and a new product emerges to cater to this concern and this product is the remote control The idea is this device is going to allow you freedom to
避免广告，基本上掌控你自己的电视观看体验。它做到了吗？嗯，许多人可能不知道的是，正如你所暗示的那样，遥控器诞生时是一个广告杀手。它是Zeneth作为解决广告问题的方法而发明的。遥控器的早期版本看起来像左轮手枪，一把你可以射击广告的枪，我想基本上是调低音量或切换频道。它被营销为服务于个人。然而，从长远来看，我想我们大多数人
Avoid the advertisements to basically be in charge of your own television watching experience. Did it do that? Well, what many people may not know is that the remote control as you Suggested was born as an ad killer It was invented by Zeneth as a solution to the problem of advertising. The early versions of the remote control looked like a revolver a gun that you would shoot out the ad, I guess basically turning out down the volume or switching channels. And it was marketed as serving the individual. In the long term however, and I think most
都经历过这一点。它并没有完全达到那些目的。它反而开始启用一种不同类型的行为，频道冲浪，你坐在那里按按钮，按按钮，按按钮，有时一按就是几个小时。所以存在这种悖论，有时旨在解放我们或赋予我们权力的设备，却以完全不同的方式奴役我们，主要是因为我们薄弱的自控力。这种缺乏自控力是注意力商人几乎每一项新发明的核心。即使人们试图从一种形式的思维控制中解放自己，熟练的商人也会找到新的方法来破坏人们移开视线的能力。在这场军备竞赛中，他们最大的胜利之一是电视体育的发现。体育的转折点是1958年国家橄榄球联盟锦标赛，
of us have experienced this. I didn't quite have those purposes. It instead began enabling a different kind of behavior, channel surfing, where you sort of sit there and push the button, push the button, push the button, sometimes for hours on end. So there's this paradox that sometimes devices designed to liberate us or empower us and enslaving us
小马队和巨人队之间进行的“有史以来最伟大的比赛”。这是一场令人难以置信的激动人心的橄榄球比赛。但更重要的是，橄榄球在电视上并没有被大量观众观看，直到那时没有人完全理解它是多么引人入胜。事实证明，直到今天，虽然有一些减弱，但体育观众非常忠诚，他们是一个极其有价值的，也许是最有价值的注意力收割机会。这是电视在1950年代的另一项发明。我必须说，作为一个体育迷，我发现自己坐在比赛两分钟警告时的两分半钟广告中，
in completely different ways, mainly because of our weak powers of self-control. This lack of self-control lies at the very heart of nearly every new invention of the attention merchants. Even as people try to liberate themselves from one form of mind control, skilled merchants find new ways to undermine people's ability to look away. One of their biggest victories in this arms race was a discovery of televised sports. And the turning point for sports was the 1958 National Football League Championships,
问自己，你知道，我到底在做什么？但当然，我每个星期天都继续这样做。我认为这是50年代的旧模式在流媒体和其他竞争对手时代仍然具有影响力的少数几次之一。体育是传统广播模式的直布罗陀。正如你所说，我也喜欢体育，当我在其他任何事情上都不会这样做时，我会坐着看完广告。所以我认为你是对的。随着电视网络捕获了人们思维空间中越来越大的份额，新进入者发现很难竞争。制作引人注目的电视节目很昂贵。
the game of the greatest game ever played between the Colts and the Giants. And it was incredibly exciting football game. But more to the point, football had not been watched on TV by large audiences, and no one quite understood to that point just how captivating it was. And it has proven to this day, there's been some weakening, but sports audiences are very loyal, they're an exceptionally valuable, maybe the most valuable attention harvesting opportunity. And this is another of TV's inventions in the 1950s. I have to say as a sports fan myself, I find myself sitting through two and a half minutes of ads at the two minute warning of a game,
1992年，MTV正在寻找一种在不花太多钱的情况下抓住并保持人们注意力的方法。他们想出的解决方案……这是一个真实的故事。真实故事。真实故事。七个陌生人被选中住在一起，并录下了他们的生活以找出发生了什么。什么？当人们停止不礼貌时。
asking myself, you know, what in God's name am I doing? But of course, I keep doing that every Sunday. It's one of the few times I think that the old model, the 50, still has its sway in an era of, you know, streaming and other competitors. Sports is the Gibraltar of the traditional broadcast model. And as you said, I like sports too and I will sit through ads when I would never do it for anything else. So I think you're right. As the television networks captured an ever larger share of people's mind space, new entrants found it difficult to compete. Producing compelling television was expensive.
你能接电话吗？并开始重新加入真实世界。谈谈这个想法，即这在某种程度上是今天我们所说的真人秀电视的发现。是的，绝对是。90年代的MTV开始认为，好吧，迈克尔·杰克逊的视频时代可能即将结束，或者杜兰杜兰，人们不会再看视频了。我们需要别的东西。他们实际上考虑过转播橄榄球。
In 1992, MTV was looking for a way to grab and hold people's attention without spending too much money. The solution they came up with... This is the true story. True story. True story. Seven strangers picked to live in a lot and had the lives taped to find out what happened. What? When people stopped the impolite.
他们做了一段时间的游戏节目。但后来有人想到，他们真正需要的是肥皂剧。正如我们已经暗示的那样，他们看了肥皂剧，意识到它们太贵了。MTV的运营成本很低。除了他们用派对和一些最低工资支付的VJ外，他们基本上没有成本。所以他们有了把一群业余爱好者或普通人聚在一起，把他们放在房子里，然后看看会发生什么的想法。房子在苏荷区，结果是一个叫《真实世界》的节目，正如你已经暗示的那样，它是真人秀电视的创始系列，实际上归根结底是由级联驱动的，你知道我们需要廉价展示它的想法。最初《真实世界》的参与者被支付了
Could you get the phone? And start getting re-up the real world. Talk about this idea that this isn't some ways the discovery of what today we would call a reality television. Yeah, so absolutely. MTV 90s started to think, well, it could be that the era of Michael Jackson's videos are coming to an end or Durand Durand, people aren't going to watch videos anymore. We need something else. They actually thought about broadcasting football.
$1,400美元用于整个拍摄。所以，你知道，不是很贵。给参与者的论点是，我们将支付给你的不是美元和美分，而是我们将用注意力和名声来支付给你。是的，这在某种程度上是天才的发现。一种说法是，你知道，与支付高薪，特别是给著名演员相比，你可以转而
They did a game show for a little while. But then someone had the idea that what they really needed was a soap opera. And as we already suggested, they looked at soap opera and realized that they were far too expensive. MTV was run on the cheap. They had basically no costs other than the VJs who they paid in parties and some minimal salary. So they had the idea of getting a bunch of amateurs or regular people together Putting them in a house and then just seeing what happened the house was in Soho result was a show called the real world and as you already Suggested it was a founding series of reality Television and driven really at bottom by cascading, you know the idea that we need to show it on the cheap the participants in the original Real world were paid
让，你知道，所谓的正常，稍微正常的人来做这件事，因为他们自己会成为名人的想法，至少会持续一段时间。成千上万的人采用了这个想法并付诸实践。你不再需要成为一家大公司才能成为注意力商人。我们桌上和手中的屏幕使一种新型商人成为可能，他们发现了越来越强大的方法来让我们不断回来。这将在休息后讨论，但首先，我们需要一点时间通过我们赞助商的一些信息来货币化你的思维空间。是的，我们也是注意力商人。
$1,400 for the entire set. So, you know, not very expensive. And the argument made to the participants was, we are gonna pay you not in dollars and cents, but we're gonna pay you in attention and fame. Yes, this was the genius discovery in a way. It's one way of putting it is that, you know, as opposed to shelling out for a big salary, especially for a famous actor, you could instead
我是香卡·维丹塔姆，你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。今天我们正在与作家蒂姆·吴讨论他的书《注意力商人》，这是一场进入我们大脑的史诗般的争夺。注意力商人是电视节目、报纸文章和播客，它们吸引你，然后将你的注意力卖给广告商。我们都有梦想，只需支付运费和手续费，这就是订购方式。互联网重新定义了注意力商人可以是什么以及是谁的概念。你不需要成为财富500强公司或广告巨头。
get, you know, so-called normal, somewhat normal people to do it for the idea that they would themselves become celebrities, at least for a little while. Thousands of people have taken this idea and run with it. You don't need to be a large corporation anymore to be an attention merchant. The screens on our desks and in our hands have enabled a new breed of merchants who have found ever more powerful ways to keep us coming back. That's coming up after the break, but first, we need a moment to monetize your mind space with some messages from our sponsors. Yes, we're Attention Martians too.
你可以是像乔纳·佩雷蒂（Jonah Peretti）这样的人。2001年，这位麻省理工学院的研究生有一个想法。他决定订购一些印有“血汗工厂”（sweatshop）字样的个性化耐克运动鞋。耐克并没有真正接受这个建议，他们拒绝了它，或者某个员工认为它是不适当的俚语。他回信指出，血汗工厂不是俚语，它在字典里。
I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Today we're talking with author Tim Wu about his book, The Attention Merchants, the epic scramble to get inside our heads. Attention merchants are television shows, newspaper articles and podcasts that draw you in and then sell your attention to advertisers. We all have out of our dreams, just face every chipping and handling, here's how to order. The internet has redefined the notion of what and who an attention merchant can be. You don't need to be a Fortune 500 company or an advertising behemoth.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们与作家蒂姆·吴探讨他的著作《注意力商人》，书中讲述了争夺我们大脑控制权的史诗级博弈。注意力商人是指那些通过电视节目、报纸文章和播客吸引您，然后将您的注意力出售给广告商的人。我们都有自己的梦想，面对各种琐碎的处理，以下是订购方式。互联网重新定义了注意力商人的概念和身份。您不必非得是财富500强企业或广告巨头。
You can be someone like Jonah Peretti. In 2001, the MIT grad student had an idea. He decided to order some personalized Nike sneakers with the word sweatshop printed on them. Nike didn't really take to that suggestion that they rejected it or some employee did as an inappropriate slang. He wrote back and pointed out that the sweatshop wasn't slang, that it was in the dictionary.
您可以是像乔纳·佩雷蒂那样的人。2001年，这位麻省理工学院的研究生萌生了一个想法。他决定定制一些印有“血汗工厂”字样的耐克运动鞋。耐克公司并不接受这个建议，他们拒绝了，或者说某位员工认为这是不恰当的俚语。他回信指出，“血汗工厂”并非俚语，而是字典里的词汇。
And they just canceled the order and he wrote a final email saying, well, you know, could you please send me a picture of the 12-year-old who's making my shoes. He also went on to write a blog post about his experience or shared this material, uh, described to me what happened and sort of the turn of events that turned this, you know, relatively innocuous private interaction into something that was close to a global phenomenon. Well, Jonah Peretti was that, here he was in the early 2000s and he touched a live wire that no one really understood well, which was the tendency of certain stories. I don't know if it was quite a blog post.
他们取消了订单，他写了最后一封邮件说，好吧，你知道，能不能请你给我发一张那个制作我鞋子的12岁孩子的照片。他还写了一篇关于他经历的博客文章，或者分享了这些材料，呃，向我描述了发生的事情，以及一系列事件如何将这种相对无害的私人互动变成了一种近乎全球性的现象。嗯，乔纳·佩雷蒂就是这样，他在21世纪初触碰了一根没人真正理解的带电电线，那就是某些故事的传播倾向。我不知道那到底算不算一篇博客文章。
I think he just sent an email out and the email got forwarded, got forwarded, got forwarded, got forwarded, got forwarded until millions of people had seen it or read it. We now call that going viral, but that phrase didn't exist back then. You know, Jonah told me he then ended up on the, you know, today's show talking about sweatshops. The thing blew up. And, you know, that's something we're kind of more familiar with now, but the time it was a new phenomenon, especially, you know, an unknown person having their email just go viral. And it showed that there was something new and unusual about this medium, the web and the internet.
我想他只是发了一封电子邮件，然后这封邮件被转发、转发、转发、转发、转发，直到数百万人看到或读到它。我们现在称之为病毒式传播，但那个词在当时并不存在。你知道，乔纳告诉我，他后来上了那个，你知道，今日秀节目谈论血汗工厂。事情爆发了。而且，你知道，这是我们现在比较熟悉的事情，但在当时这是一种新现象，尤其是，你知道，一个不知名的人发出的电子邮件竟然病毒式传播了。这表明这种媒介，即网络和互联网，有一些新奇且不同寻常的东西。
Now Jonah, of course, was not a one-shot wonder. He went on to do several other things. In fact, he demonstrated that he had something of a knack for finding things that went viral. Describe to us some of the websites that most of us have visited that are the brainchild of Jonah Peretti. Yeah, so Jonah in some ways did a lot to invent our present. Something about virality fascinated him. I think he just thought that experience with the shoes was so strange and weird and unexpected
当然，乔纳并不是昙花一现。他后来还做了其他几件事。事实上，他证明了自己在寻找病毒式传播内容方面很有天赋。请向我们描述一下我们大多数人都访问过的、出自乔纳·佩雷蒂之手的网站。是的，乔纳在某些方面为发明我们的现在做了很多工作。关于病毒式传播的某种东西让他着迷。我想他只是觉得那次关于鞋子的经历太奇怪、太不可思议且出乎意料了
that he went back almost like a scientist to see if he could bottle that lightning. He founded two websites. One was the Huffington Post, which he co-founded with other people, including Arion Huffington, which was designed to use these sort of web techniques to push a more left-leaning form of journalism, and it was a tremendous success-transform journalism, not all in good ways, but did. But he even went further and went to the pure distillation of attention with a site name Buzzfeed Laboratories, now known as Buzzfeed, the only goal of which was the pure distillation of attention with a site name Buzzfeed Laboratories, now known as Buzzfeed.
以至于他像科学家一样回去研究是否能将那种闪电装进瓶子里。他创办了两个网站。一个是《赫芬顿邮报》，他与阿里安娜·赫芬顿等人共同创立了该网站，旨在利用这些网络技术来推动一种更偏左的报道形式，并且取得了巨大的成功——改变了新闻业，虽然不全是好的方面，但确实做到了。但他甚至走得更远，通过一个名为Buzzfeed实验室（现称为Buzzfeed）的网站，实现了对注意力的纯粹提炼，其唯一目标就是通过一个名为Buzzfeed实验室（现称为Buzzfeed）的网站，实现对注意力的纯粹提炼。
The only goal of which was the pure harvesting of attention by creating viral stories. And that Buzzfeed has obviously transformed web content today as we know it. I remember some time ago, Tim, I was watching something that was forwarded to me by a friend, and it showed a video that Buzzfeed had posted where they had a watermelon sitting on a table, it showed a video that Buzzfeed had posted where they had a watermelon
其唯一目标就是通过创造病毒式故事来纯粹地收割注意力。而Buzzfeed显然改变了我们今天所知的网络内容。我记得前段时间，蒂姆，我正在看一个朋友转发给我的东西，它展示了Buzzfeed发布的一个视频，视频里他们把一个西瓜放在桌子上，它展示了Buzzfeed发布的一个视频，视频里他们把一个西瓜
sitting on a table and these two people working at Buzzfeed essentially wrapped rubber bands around the watermelon and they kept doing so until they were probably hundreds of rubber bands. And the idea was of course that at some point the rubber bands would exert enough power on the water melon to make the watermelon explode. And you sort of knew this was going to happen, but you didn't quite know when it was going to happen. And people like me sat and watched this video on Fall 4.
放在桌子上，这两个在Buzzfeed工作的人基本上是在西瓜上缠绕橡皮筋，他们一直这样做，直到缠了可能有几百根橡皮筋。当然，其想法是，在某个时刻，橡皮筋会对西瓜施加足够的压力，使西瓜爆炸。你大概知道这会发生，但你不太确定它什么时候会发生。像我这样的人就坐在那里看这个视频，看了很久。
I don't know how long it was. It might have been even 10 or 12 minutes. And all this was of people was people putting rubber bands on a watermelon. And throughout that process, I found myself asking, why is it that I just simply, I'm not able to look away? And in some ways, it is an act of genius to create content like that.
我不知道它有多长。可能甚至有10或12分钟。而所有这些内容就是人们在西瓜上缠橡皮筋。在整个过程中，我发现自己在问，为什么我就是无法移开视线？在某种程度上，创造这样的内容是一种天才之举。
Yeah, I buzzfeed laboratories. I think the laboratories, it's an important part of the original name, is they just kept experimenting until they found stuff that for whatever reason, just grab people and wouldn't let it go. Watermelons with rubber bands, maybe more obvious ones like cat photos, they just people kept coming back. And I guess we know more about the human mind as a result of BuzzFeed's experiment on us, although I'm not really sure that we like what we found, or at least we found that the things we're interested in aren't necessarily reading Tolstoy or something, but are these strange things
是的，我Buzzfeed实验室。我认为“实验室”是原名中很重要的一部分，因为他们只是不断尝试，直到找到那些无论出于什么原因，都能抓住人们眼球且让人欲罢不能的东西。缠着橡皮筋的西瓜，也许还有更明显的猫咪照片，人们就是不断回来。我想我们因为Buzzfeed对我们的实验而对人类思维有了更多了解，尽管我不确定我们是否喜欢所发现的东西，或者至少我们发现我们感兴趣的东西不一定是读托尔斯泰之类的，而是这些奇怪的东西
like the one you mentioned. Let's talk for a moment about Silicon Valley and the work of companies like Google and Twitter and Facebook. They have in some ways become masters not just of capturing our attention, but monitoring where our attention goes and building products that cater to the drift of our attention. Talk about these new attention merchants and in some ways they're enormous power over our lives. Yeah sure. A big turning point in the history of humanity came at the end of the last century, the last millennia, when Silicon Valley, headed by Google, first
就像你提到的那个。让我们花点时间谈谈硅谷以及谷歌、Twitter和Facebook等公司的工作。他们在某种程度上不仅成为了捕捉我们注意力的专家，还成为了监控我们注意力流向并构建迎合我们注意力漂移的产品的专家。谈谈这些新的注意力商人，以及他们在某种程度上对我们生活的巨大权力。是的，当然。人类历史上一个巨大的转折点出现在上个世纪，上个千年之交，当时以谷歌为首的硅谷，首先
really started to get into advertising and turned all the resources, all the know-how, all the expertise of engineering and computer science to the art and science of capturing as much attention as possible, getting as much data as possible out of people, and reselling it to advertisers. That has been a change with profound consequences. I think many or most of us are hooked on one or more online products, which no more about us than anyone else. And frankly, I like this incredible supercomputer
真正开始涉足广告业，并将工程和计算机科学的所有资源、诀窍和专业知识转向了捕捉尽可能多注意力的艺术和科学，从人们那里获取尽可能多的数据，并将其转售给广告商。这是一个后果深远的改变。我认为我们中的许多人或大多数人都沉迷于一种或多种在线产品，它们比任何人都更了解我们。坦率地说，我喜欢这个令人难以置信的超级计算机
designed to get as much resellable attention out of us as possible. I think this is something that goes beyond even what television or radio was capable of doing because they know so much more about us. They know so much more about you, your vulnerabilities, your desires, and customized marketing can really work.
旨在从我们身上榨取尽可能多可转售的注意力。我认为这甚至超越了电视或广播所能做到的，因为它们对我们了解得更多。它们对你了解得更多，了解你的弱点、你的欲望，而定制化营销确实有效。
And it's something we really need to watch in this next decade. Many celebrities have come to understand that attention online translates to money. I was reading a website the other day that was describing the Indian cricket star, Virat Kohli, who has nearly 17 million Instagram followers. And the article said that Virat Kohli makes half a million dollars per Instagram post where he promotes a product. That is just mind-boggling.
这是我们在未来十年真正需要关注的事情。许多名人已经开始明白，在线注意力可以转化为金钱。前几天我读到一个网站，上面描述了印度板球明星维拉·科利，他拥有近1700万Instagram粉丝。文章说，维拉·科利每发布一条推广产品的Instagram帖子就能赚50万美元。这简直令人难以置信。
It does show the commercial value of attention, which is really what my book is all about. And it also speaks to the transformation of celebrity. There was once a point where famous people, say the Queen of England or a famous scientist, they sort of tried to stay out of public view. They usually had jobs other than being celebrities, say I don't know, Einstein was trying to discover things. And their mystery seemed to add to the sense of wonder or fame.
这确实显示了注意力的商业价值，这正是我的书所探讨的主题。它也说明了名人的转变。曾经有一段时间，名人，比如英国女王或著名的科学家，他们尽量远离公众视野。他们通常有除了当名人之外的工作，比如我不知道，爱因斯坦当时正试图发现一些东西。而他们的神秘感似乎增加了人们对他们的惊叹或名声。
That's not our model at all. Celebrities or aspiring celebrities seek to e-cout any minute or second they can get of our attention and stay there, never go away. And as you suggested, there's commercial reasons to do so that you can frankly make a lot of money not only doing your job, but just by being famous. And I think maybe Paris Hilton gets some credit for the theory of just being famous for being famous, sick. Famous for being famous is the phrase, but certainly a celebrity has transformed it our times. It isn't just mega stars who can monetize their celebrity.
那根本不是我们的模式。名人们或渴望成为名人的人寻求榨取他们能得到的每一分钟或每一秒的注意力，并留在那里，永远不离开。正如你所暗示的，这样做有商业原因，坦率地说，你不仅可以通过做你的工作赚很多钱，仅仅通过出名也能赚很多钱。我想也许帕丽斯·希尔顿因“因出名而出名”的理论而获得了一些赞誉。因出名而出名是一个短语，但毫无疑问，名人已经改变了我们的时代。不仅仅是超级巨星才能将他们的名气货币化。
Increasingly, micro celebrities, often called influencers, are finding there's real money to be made in harvesting the attention of their friends and followers. Hi, I'm Sue Tran. I'm currently an associate creative director. We're finally 29 working in the brand and content space. I also have a micro-large following on Instagram with my Instagram handle, Sue Tran, with three ads. Sue Tran has about 23,000 followers on Instagram.
越来越多被称为“网红”的微型名人发现，收割朋友和粉丝的注意力确实能赚到钱。嗨，我是苏·特兰。我目前是一名副创意总监。我们29岁，在品牌和内容领域工作。我在Instagram上也有一个微型的大量粉丝，我的Instagram账号是Sue Tran，带三个下划线。苏·特兰在Instagram上有大约23,000名粉丝。
She joined the site five years ago. Since then, she's built up a following of people interested in food and art around New York City. Scattered among some 1,500 photos are pictures of Yankee candles, portable printers, and most recently, pictures of Sue posing with a Google Pixel smartphone. Google is actually through an influencer agency. Influencer marketing agencies has been growing in the last like one or two years just because people want to monetize influential Instagram
她五年前加入了这个网站。从那时起，她建立了一群对纽约市美食和艺术感兴趣的粉丝。在约1500张照片中，散布着洋基蜡烛、便携式打印机，以及最近苏与谷歌Pixel智能手机合影的照片。谷歌实际上是通过一家网红代理机构。网红营销机构在过去一两年里一直在增长，仅仅是因为人们想要将有影响力的Instagram用户
and bloggers and all that stuff. So they kind of create a platform to make it easier for influencers to seek out sponsors or sponsors to seek out them. Sue says companies pay influencers based on the number of followers they have. I have a rate of 150. There's a homemade quality to Sue's sponsored posts. Some of them are obviously a little bit more staged, but I don't think I would ever post anything that I didn't feel like was 100% me. Companies want these messages to feel like authentic recommendations from one friend to
和博主等货币化。所以他们创造了一个平台，让网红更容易寻找赞助商，或者让赞助商更容易找到他们。苏说，公司根据网红拥有的粉丝数量向他们支付费用。我的费率是150。苏的赞助帖子有一种自制的感觉。其中一些显然更具表演性，但我不认为我会发布任何我觉得不是100%真实自我的内容。公司希望这些信息感觉像是来自一个朋友的真实推荐
another rather than advertising messages directed by a multi-billion dollar company. In one picture, Sue poses with her Google phone in front of her building in Brooklyn. In another, she's holding the phone while sitting in a Chinese restaurant. To a friend, it might look like she loves her Google phone, but... Don't tell anyone, I'm still on my iPhone. It just is, indicates a new type of media environment where, as you suggested, many more people can be famous, not in the older traditional sense of, you know, everyone in America knows your face or everyone in the
而不是由一家价值数十亿美元的公司指导的广告信息。在一张照片中，苏拿着她的谷歌手机在布鲁克林的公寓楼前摆姿势。在另一张照片中，她坐在一家中餐馆里拿着手机。对朋友来说，这看起来可能像是她很喜欢她的谷歌手机，但是……别告诉任何人，我还在用我的iPhone。这只是表明了一种新的媒体环境，正如你所暗示的，更多的人可以出名，不是那种老式的传统意义上的，你知道，美国每个人都知道你的脸，或者世界上的
world knows your face, which was the old criteria for People Magazine putting your face on the cover. But that, you know, millions of people or hundreds of thousands of people know who you are, and therefore in some smaller way you were micro or nano-famous. When we think of celebrities, we think of people most often in movies and on television. My name is Donald Trump and I'm the largest real estate developer in New York. You have a particular interpretation of how the apprentice led to Donald Trump's election as president.
每个人都知道你的脸，这是《人物》杂志把你放在封面上旧的标准。而是，你知道，数百万人或数十万人知道你是谁，因此在某种较小的程度上，你是微型或纳米级的名人。当我们想到名人时，我们最常想到的是电影和电视里的人。我是唐纳德·特朗普，我是纽约最大的房地产开发商。你对《学徒》如何导致唐纳德·特朗普当选总统有独特的解读。
Yes, I think that Donald Trump threw the apprentice, and to some degree, other parts of his life understood deeply the power of capturing and using human attention. Now, on the apprentice, I think he studied what it takes to capture an audience, some of these things we talked about, BuzzFeed, the sort of plot twists, the unusual, surprising behavior. And I think he has, in his presidency uh and during his campaign sought as his primary directive to always win the battle for attention sometimes even losing or appearing to lose it doesn't matter as long as there's a good show a big fight and everyone's
是的，我认为唐纳德·特朗普通过《学徒》，在某种程度上，通过他生活的其他部分，深刻理解了捕捉和利用人类注意力的力量。现在，在《学徒》节目中，我认为他研究了捕捉观众需要什么，我们谈到的一些事情，Buzzfeed，那种情节转折，不寻常、令人惊讶的行为。我认为他在他的总统任期内，呃，在竞选期间，将始终赢得注意力之战作为他的首要指令，有时甚至输掉或看起来输掉也无所谓，只要有一场好戏、一场大争斗，每个人都在
paying attention to me and his mind he thinks he's won and to some degree it is true than any of us would like to admit. At some deep level there's some genius to it. Understanding that the battle for attention is primary to a lot of other battles. The whole country and to some degree the world is reacting to his agenda, his presence, everything he does. That's also known as power. Even if people are resisting you, they're still paying attention to you. And so, you know, the mental resources of the entire nation, much of the world, have been devoted to this one figure, Mr. Donald Trump. When you step back and look at this long arc of how attention merchants have captured
关注我，在他看来，他认为他赢了，在某种程度上，这比我们任何人都愿意承认的要真实。在某种深层层面上，这确实有一种天才之处。理解注意力之战是许多其他战斗的首要任务。整个国家，在某种程度上整个世界，都在对他的议程、他的存在、他所做的一切做出反应。这也称为权力。即使人们在抵制你，他们仍然在关注你。所以，你知道，整个国家的精神资源，世界的大部分，都致力于这个单一的人物，唐纳德·特朗普先生。当你退后一步，审视注意力商人如何捕捉
our attention and monetized it and sold it and found ways to figure out what works and what doesn't work. Are there broad patterns that emerge about human nature and human psychology? Are there lessons to be drawn about how the mind works from the story of the attention merchants? Yeah, I think there are. So first of all, there's lessons as to how we decide what to pay attention to, it's a mixture of voluntary and involuntary mechanisms. The science suggests, and I think the history suggests, it's true.
我们的注意力，将其货币化、出售，并找到方法弄清楚什么有效、什么无效的漫长历程时。关于人性与人类心理，是否出现了广泛的模式？从注意力商人的故事中，关于思维如何运作，有什么教训可以吸取吗？是的，我认为有。首先，关于我们如何决定关注什么，这既有主动机制，也有被动机制。科学表明，我认为历史也表明，这是事实。
So we like to think we control what we pay attention to, but in fact, we can sort of be conditioned or involuntarily attracted to things. If you ever found yourself clicking on Facebook and wondering why did I do that, or if you ever find yourself startled by an ad and watching it, not sure what got you there, you'll know that it's not fully within our voluntary control. Part of this book is motivated by deep interest in human freedom and, you know, a sense that
所以我们喜欢认为我们控制着我们关注什么，但事实上，我们可能会被条件反射或不由自主地被某些事物吸引。如果你曾经发现自己点击Facebook并想知道我为什么要那样做，或者如果你曾经发现自己被一则广告吓到并观看它，不确定是什么让你点击了它，你就会知道这并不完全在我们的主动控制之下。这本书的一部分动机是对人类自由的深切关注，你知道，一种感觉，即
we can lose our freedom and become entrapped really by doing what we think are voluntary choices. I mean, I don't have to read email, I don't have to be writing tweets or something. Nonetheless, these voluntary choices in a environment, can leave one trapped. Another motivation for this book is the experience, which I'm sure many of listeners will have had, where you go to your computer and you have the idea you're gonna write just one email,
我们可能会失去自由，并真正被我们认为是主动选择的事情所困住。我的意思是，我不必阅读电子邮件，我不必写推文之类的。尽管如此，这些在环境中的主动选择，可能会让人陷入困境。这本书的另一个动机是这种经历，我相信许多听众都有过，当你走到电脑前，你打算只写一封电子邮件，
and you sit down and suddenly an hour goes by, maybe two hours, and you don't know what happened. The sort of surrender of control over our lives, the loss of control, to me speaks deeply to this challenge of freedom and what it means to be autonomous in our time and have a life where you've sort of, to some degree, chosen what you want to do. These are values that seem to me under threat in our times. So there's been a war for our attention for a very long time.
然后你坐下来，突然一个小时过去了，也许两个小时，你不知道发生了什么。这种对我们生活控制权的放弃，这种控制权的丧失，对我来说深刻地说明了自由的挑战，以及在我们的时代成为一个自主的人意味着什么，以及拥有一个你已经在某种程度上选择了你想做什么的生活意味着什么。这些价值观在我看来在我们的时代受到了威胁。所以，一场争夺我们注意力的战争已经持续了很长时间。
At least a century, probably much longer than that. Are we just helpless victims in this war where people are waging this battle for our attention? Is there a way that we can, in some ways, take back this battlefield and own our own minds again? Yeah, this is, as you said, something only a century old, advertising 100 years ago was just getting started. So we're in a relatively new, over the course of human civilization environment. And I think we can adapt.
至少一个世纪，可能比那长得多。在这场人们为争夺我们注意力而进行的战争中，我们只是无助的受害者吗？有没有一种方法，我们可以以某种方式夺回这个战场，并再次拥有我们自己的思想？是的，正如你所说，这只是一个世纪前的事情，100年前的广告业才刚刚起步。所以我们处于人类文明进程中一个相对较新的环境中。我认为我们可以适应。
We still have our individuality and ultimately some choice. Now, the challenge is that we face an industry which has spent a century inventing and developing techniques to get us hooked to harvest as much attention as possible. And they're good at it. But we do have choices, and I think it begins with the idea that attention is a resource that you own it, and that one should be very conscious about how it's being spent.
我们仍然拥有我们的个性，最终还有一些选择权。现在，挑战在于我们面对的是一个花费了一个世纪来发明和开发技术以让我们上瘾、以收割尽可能多注意力的行业。他们很擅长这一点。但我们确实有选择，我认为这始于这样一个观念：注意力是一种你拥有的资源，一个人应该非常清醒地意识到它是如何被花费的。
I was motivated writing this book by the work of William James, the philosopher, and he pointed out something very straightforward, which is, you know, at the end of William James, the philosopher. And he pointed out something very straightforward, which is at the end of your days, your life will have been what you paid attention to. And so deciding how that vital resource is spent, in my view, is the key to life, frankly, the key to it, meaning, the key to doing and having a life which you think is meaningful.
我写这本书的动机是威廉·詹姆斯的著作，这位哲学家指出了一件非常直截了当的事情，那就是，你知道，在威廉·詹姆斯这位哲学家生命的尽头。他指出了一件非常直截了当的事情，那就是在你生命的尽头，你的人生将是你所关注的事物的总和。因此，决定如何花费这种至关重要的资源，在我看来，是生活的关键，坦率地说，是意义的关键，是过上你认为有意义的生活的关键。
["Minecraft Theme Song"] Tim Wu is a professor at Columbia Law School. He is the author of the Attention Merchants, the Epic Scramble to Get Inside Our Heads. Tim, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Yeah, thank you so much. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, Laura Quarelle, and Andrew Chadwick.
["Minecraft主题曲"] 蒂姆·吴是哥伦比亚法学院的教授。他是《注意力商人：进入我们大脑的史诗争夺战》一书的作者。蒂姆，感谢你今天参加Hidden Brain节目。是的，非常感谢。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、瑞安·卡茨、克里斯汀·王、奥特姆·巴恩斯、劳拉·夸雷尔和安德鲁·查德威克。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsunk hero this week is Devon Trainer. Devon works in the content operations division at Stitcher and he's been helping us with a project that involves uploading a massive amount of audio. Devon has been helping us with this project since last fall and now that we're getting close to the finish line we cannot imagine how we could have accomplished it without its hard work. Thank you, Devon. If you like hearing about new research and ideas about human behavior, be sure to subscribe
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是德文·特雷纳。德文在Stitcher的内容运营部门工作，他一直在帮助我们完成一个涉及上传海量音频的项目。德文从去年秋天开始就一直在帮助我们完成这个项目，现在我们即将接近终点线，我们无法想象如果没有他的辛勤工作，我们该如何完成它。谢谢你，德文。如果你喜欢听关于人类行为的新研究和想法，请务必订阅
to our newsletter. You can sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's N-E-W-S dot hiddenbrain dot org. You'll find puzzles, interesting social science research, and a moment of joy. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的时事通讯。你可以在news.hiddenbrain.org注册。那是N-E-W-S点hiddenbrain点org。你会发现谜题、有趣的社会科学研究和快乐的时刻。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。你 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。